Cell transport is the process of how things move in or out of the cell through the cell membrane
There are two broad categories of cell Transport
The first Category is passive transport, for a cell passive transport means
It's an automatic process that doesn't require any input of energy
for example
Diffusion is a passive process in which particles move either into or out of the cell from an area of higher
concentration to an area of lower concentration
The cell doesn't use any energy when this happens
The second Category of cell Transport is active Transport
This is when particles move from an area of lower concentration to an area of higher concentration
when particles move against the concentration gradient
Energy is required often to allow protein pumps to assist in Particle Movement
why would the cell need to move particles from a low to high concentration and expend energy to do it
An Important example is seen in your heart muscle cells
In order for your heart to beat there are certain molecules that have to move from an area of low concentration
to an area of high concentration
for those cardiac muscle cells to work
So the main things to remember are passive transport happens automatically with no energy required
while active transport needs energy for it to occur